Bye bye boo!
Welcome in, welcome in!
Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Welcome in!
Hi, hi, hi!
Hi, hi!
Hello!
Oh, oh, Tensetsu EXE official channel!
Thanks for pinning the link oh my gosh we're in space yuppie
chat is frozen oh my gosh i said thank you i forget every
time that you i have to do this now this is a new youtube
feature i love it i love it so much space is the place yeah
we're playing prog mana today oh my gosh i've been so
excited when i was in even a demo setup to play this and i
stopped myself but i did take a picture but i stopped myself
from playing because i was like no i have this stream and i
want my first impression to be on stream so i i i chose i
but i was so excited spice which one of you are going to
wait which one of which one are you going to possess i don't
even know what that means Tentanagan welcome to membership
thank you thank you Steiner promoting that but this is a
sponsored stream so thank you so much Capcom for sponsoring
me today to play
I'm I'm I'm I'm a fan of Capcom games so uh thanks Capcom
whenever there's a another ace attorney I'm your girl it's
funny because um i don't really receive like pr packages or
anything like that um but capcom has always been the only
ones to send me pr packages so i got one for like for uh the
miles edgeworth game i got one for monster hunter i the
monster hunter one was so cool Because it came in like a...
In like a...
How do you say?
It was like a treasure chest.
It was so cool.
But today we're Pragmata-ing.
So if you are interested in the game, if you think it looks
pretty neat yourself, or you want to see how it plays, there
is a demo.
So you can check the link in the description, in the pinned
comment, or whatever Steiner will be periodically posting
for me.
So, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Also, though, I'll give you a little bit.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my gosh, Vittorio.
Thank you.
Oh, my gosh.
Pragmaton, it's so much, too.
I'm so, Me too.
Thank you!
Thank you for the message!
Thank you, thank you!
Message, thank you!
Thank you so much for the very big...
Thank you so much!
But to give you guys a little bit of extra information on
what Pragmata is like, it's, like I said, it's the newest
game from Capcom!
This time though, we have a third person shooter set in
space oh my gosh sci-fi let's go but it's also also the same
team behind resident evil and devil may cry oh my god devil
may cry i've been dodging spoilers all week i will see like
a clip of diana and i'm like oh my gosh wait i want to watch
so bad because she's so i've okay i've watched a couple but
she's just so cute i can't help so um yes yes yes yes but we
are not just uh you know pew pewing no no first we it's it
is the it is a it is a you've heard of hack and slash but
have you heard of hack and shoot but it is not like a wait
that's a shooting noise it's not like a shrink shrink
hacking no no hacking noise yeah It is instead a beep boop
hacking noise.
First we must hack to expose the enemy's weak points.
And then we must shoot to destroy the enemy.
So each battle kind of turns into a bit of a puzzle.
Which, oh my gosh, you guys know how much I love hacking and
puzzles.
So super hacka.
Desumehi.
Cute me to cute game sounds like a good Sunday.
Oh yeah.
i meant who are you going to possess diana or dad what do
you mean
no i will protect diana at all costs yeah but yeah so that
makes each battle kind of interesting we have to get a have
a different approach for each each each enemy that we face
and um we got a hack we got a shoot we got a we got a we got
a dodge we got a we got a game diana is chat and minto's
child oh yes wait it's
all coming up minto yeah we gotta lock in gamers halo jones
thank you so much for the five gifted kinocha thank you
welcome to membership thank you make sense to me she said
yes huh huh anyway let me finish my spiel Like I mentioned
earlier, there's a free demo available on Steam, on PS5, on
Xbox, on the Switch 2.
Yeah, yeah.
Guys, I almost went and got a Switch 2 today.
I'm not going to lie.
I'm scared of the pricing going up again.
I was like, do I just go, do I just get a Switch 2?
I will be playing this on PC, though.
But I do, I am, I don't know how, wait.
I don't know how other people have been playing but I will
be playing with my controller I wanted to test it out with
controller so um yes yes yes uh I don't know I feel I felt I
felt that controller was maybe um better choice for this so
yeah yeah yeah yeah mouse for aiming controller for hacking
really oh my gosh wait that'd be great what i okay i also
have another secret um i i turned on aim assist i i fully
disclose everything to you guys i turned on aim assist since
i'm using controller
maybe though if it's annoying i'll turn it off maybe if i
feel like an actual gamer i'll be like no i can do this i
can do this you're so brave i know with you guys I'm honest
with you guys it's not cheating it's literally it's
literally in the settings if they didn't want you to use it
they wouldn't have it as an option now would they hmm hmm if
you're using control or aim assist just make sense that's
what I'm saying that's what I'm saying but let's try Yeah,
I'm so excited.
Yeah.
And I think I hit everything.
And we're going to play the game.
And everything.
Okie dokie.
Let's go.
Oh, what's the standard?
I feel like calling it casual.
It makes me feel...
Don't call me a casual.
this mode is recommended for players who like action games
this is the normal difficulty setting the difficulty can be
changed to casual when incapacitated okay wow that's so
funny i love games i let you change it though in the middle
of the game standard isn't too bad my ship oh my gosh i'm
the first minke on the mode Yeah!
Easy bonus.
Now selectable.
I
repeat.
This is research vessel Eurotis.
Identification number.
Delta, Lima, Papa, 1, 2, 9, or 4, Alpha.
Over.
This is research vessel Eurotis.
Edis, do you copy?
Over.
Come on.
Uh-oh.
Still not responsible Oh my god, he's coming in, grabbing.
Okay, no AI.
No auto-landing.
We're going in manually.
I love the spacesuits, though.
They look so good.
Just hold on to your lunch.
Bring it in, Hugh.
All right, Hugh.
Wait.
Sidney control your way.
You got this, Hugh.
Isn't that me?
Wait a second.
Am I having to land?
Switching to manual control.
Oh, no.
You don't want me to land.
Starting LSTV check.
lights oh lights on lights on landing struts down and green
green trusters and breaks operational I have faith in you
Minto we're clear for landing oh no no don't make me do it
don't make me land I'll crash the ship Wow what is this
place I I can't believe they could just print something that
big.
What do you mean print?
This is 3D printed?
3D printed.
That's Luna filming for you.
Its applications are practically...
Oh my god!
Wow, they actually are printing it!
You can create almost anything as long as you have a
blueprint.
What?
The future.
It'd be nice if they could whip up someone to answer our
call.
Yeah, so true.
We flew all the way out here to clean up their mess.
Things they could do with me to some...
person.
Well, then let's get in there and scope it out.
Corporate's waiting.
Wow.
Wow, they're just, they're just, they're just rebooping it.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, good.
Landing is not part of the tutorial.
Shady-knocked is that good.
I don't know if you're lying.
This technology We need it.
Batteries on, everyone.
And don't forget to sink in.
I'm scared.
Is this going to turn into like a...
Oh, no.
What happened to everybody on board?
Maybe that's why nobody's answering.
Wait a second.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Actually, this is a shooting game.
What am I shooting?
Uh-oh.
Wait a second.
Everything all right?
What the heck?
Grab sinks aren't working.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I'm scared!
Nice.
Watch your step.
Ken, come on.
Uh-oh.
Just give me a moment here.
Ken's not you.
Oh no, Ken.
Ken, watch your step, Ken.
Ken's kind of moy.
Was there a welcome party?
I can't believe I missed my daughter's birthday for this.
No!
You got kids?
He's one day before retirement.
Oh, God.
Oh, this is so bad.
I wouldn't trade it for a thing.
Is this game going to convince everybody to have children?
Wait, it's so over.
Wait, this is so bad.
Wait, why is nobody...
Oh, no.
I just...
You know, I only thought of Diana in this entire...
This entire situation.
I didn't even think about...
about why I was needing to shoot.
And or anything.
Just get in and get out.
No, don't say that.
That's another flag.
Oh my gosh.
After Hugh.
Get it?
Wow.
Also, this game looks insane.
This game looks so good.
Wow.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh.
I have realized also just now I didn't really change any
settings, so.
Hopefully with all my VTuber stuff, everything's good.
Wow.
Where are we going?
Where are we going, team?
Whoa, what's going on in here?
Man, these people sure love printing.
Oh, yeah, that's actually anybody with a 3D printer.
Literally.
Literally anybody with a 3D printer is doing this.
You wouldn't, is anyone, oh no, welcome to dad's space.
Wait, for real?
What, what are they printing?
Because it's been spring for so long, I'm just seeing
barrels of pollen.
else i'm guessing we go up here lots of space noises wow not
gonna lie kind of digging the view from here too holy moly
i'm digging the view wow wow this is crazy wow i want this
as like a wallpaper Oh my gosh.
Like, uh, you know how, like, you can have, like, a live
wallpaper, right?
That's what I want this.
Oh my gosh.
It's so nice.
Thanks, Diner.
Yo, you.
Check out that big rig.
Can it really make anything?
Slap that in wallpaper, engine.
That's what I'm saying.
Sorry about my thing.
Hey, Nikki.
Fill us in.
I see someone didn't do their homework.
to you, Ken.
I'm going on ahead.
Yeah, I just started the game.
It's not just any 3D printer.
It's called a limb replicator.
Limb replicator.
Now, what do you want to know?
Everything.
Let's say you can print almost anything.
Okay.
I heard this stuff it makes breaks easy.
So, it seems crazy they're printing something that big.
Uh-oh.
You're right.
Limb products tend to be on the delicate side.
But it's just cheaper to rebuild something than to improve
its quality.
wait you saying this place could just collapse wait a second
come on man you know better than that they wouldn't skimp on
safety standards no no one would ever do that it's cheaper
to rebuild wait a second let me clarify buildings are made
with a specialized replicator and that means wait a second
luna filament is combined with other materials and stability
is improved at the cost of complexity so it's a model that
only handles construction bingo any other imagine houses
though thanks though wasn't as tricky as i thought i like
ted oh so maybe you can explain it next time he's kind of
mooy oh whoa whoa can i like oh wait what am i doing here
hold on i'm It's pressing the other things, but no buttons
do anything else.
That's fine.
Nano-driven power supply.
Whoa.
He's kind of...
Hmm.
Sometimes I just...
Okay, there we go.
The terminal's up ahead.
Time to test out your thrusters.
My thrusters.
I love space.
What are we doing?
Run, jump, and hover.
You can climb the cargo to get up here.
No stairs?
Really?
Construction still underway.
Oh, well.
Oh, I got a Luna filament.
Refined from a material unique to the moon known as Lunum.
A Luna filament can absorb and copy any information it comes
in contact with required for various upgrades in the
shelter.
Nice.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, my jump is crazy now.
Over here.
Yes, sir.
Wait, wait, wait, make it!
I don't think I jumped.
Wait, there's more down there.
Just kidding.
It's a good thing I fell.
I did that on purpose because I obviously saw that all on
the ground.
And there's definitely more over here.
See, I'm not a liar.
I'm not a liar.
Is there any inside here?
No.
I'm showing you all the places where you can get it.
Like right there.
Like right here.
See?
Oh, wow.
Look, I'm noticing the gamer.
The gamer tarp.
What is that?
Oh wait, I think that's the previous room just from up
above.
Nice.
Any more?
Okay.
What are all these things for anyway?
I guess sector six is not important.
We're doing our very cool dramatic walk-in.
Yes.
What a mess.
Where is everybody?
What are those?
What was that?
Wait.
Don't walk.
I'm scared.
I don't know who I'm hanging out with.
It's not Nicholas or Ken.
What are those?
It's fine.
What's this rubble doing here?
I'll blast it.
We're going to need some backup.
Nicholas, Ken.
Wait, no, are you summoning a robot?
Uh-oh.
Um.
We are printing the robot as we...
What?
There was... What?
Oh my god.
Uh-oh.
Welcome to the cradle.
Please state your request.
Clear us a path.
Wait, where are those guys coming from?
Take us to the data center.
as you wish why why they make the neck so long sheesh what
went down here yeah
the vtuber neck mine's not that long actually i've always
worn collars you can never tell yeah and then they send us
when the thing needs fixing push uh-oh
he's right there he can hear you i don't know kind of like
this one i like him man they're really not gonna come out
here and meet us yeah something's off something's very off i
didn't go on fire everyone did they what's that what's
happening what's Nothing better happened to Ken.
Oh no.
Ken?
Seismic activity.
Did I- Seismic?
Moon quake?
Oh geez, that's actually really bad.
That wasn't Ken, was it?
Ken!
Oh, we're with chains.
But our crew...
Oh, Ken is fine.
Ken is fine.
James, no!
Captain!
Oh my god.
What is going on?
Here, oh no.
Oh, let the robot the robot Oh no.
GG, everybody.
She's here!
Do you guys notice my hair too?
I wanted to match a little bit.
I wish to see the baby.
My daughter.
Finally.
I'm a parrot.
it whoa she knows how to use this though
integrating luna filament nano weave
she's well trained by your medical diagnostics online oh my
god you don't you don't sound so good you sound pretty bad
actually Oh nice!
Vital's stable.
Awakening subject.
Hugh Williams.
Accurate mint height.
What do you mean?
She's like a... She's like... She's a...
She's a baby!
There you are.
All better.
Oh, she's so cute.
She's so cute!
Yeah, give him a little helmet slap.
You pets me up.
So what is so cute?
I love how unruly her hair is.
It's all over the place.
Uh-oh.
I think red means bad.
This is Edus, your autonomous space administrator.
Unregistered get identified.
Me?
Oh.
Walker, please remove him from the premises.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Hey, watch out.
There's something right here.
I just realized the robots got their toes out.
Help!
Use your weapon to attack.
Ammo will slowly recharge after use.
Wait, the music is awesome.
Stop.
In the head!
Oh,
actually, uh, uh, good thing he's nice and slow.
In the chest!
Just kidding!
Nowhere works!
Oh, come on!
Damn it!
Aw, man!
Hey!
Get behind me!
No, she's...
Move!
She's so cute.
She just crawls on top of him.
Five hits in first and second firewall and there's no
control protocols.
Analyze this.
Converting the interrupt matrix.
Hacker voice?
She's in.
Visualization complete.
Initiating hack.
No!
Reach the green...
Tensetsu.exe!
No, that's a hack target.
Move the cursor across the hacking matrix and connect it
to...
Oh my gosh, wait, you're actually hacking like while...
Whoa!
While it's coming...
Wait, this is... this is scary.
Oh, I...
Okay, wait.
Will the cursor across the hacking matrix and connect it to
the EXE nodes to complete the hack, placing enemies in an
open state, making them vulnerable to gunfire?
Oh,
I have to like...
Oh, it's not like...
Oh, so...
It's not like D-Pod.
Interesting.
Okay, okay.
You have trained for this.
Okay.
Green.exe, the Minto hue!
Yay!
Okay, it's not D-pad.
Okay, I'm gonna have to remember that it's...
Okay.
I mean, it's easy because X is already left and B is already
right.
Yeah, time to put that...
Yeah, my hacking skills.
Okay.
And then L is reset.
What the heck was that?
There's no time to explain.
Shoot down!
Ciao!
What did you just do?
I hacked it!
Oh, she's so cute.
Nice.
Oh, don't get to.
Forget it.
Let's give him weight.
We got bigger problems.
Are there more?
James!
Captain?
Captain!
Is this a thing that opens?
No.
No, they're gonna get him!
No!
Captain!
Oh shoot.
How am I supposed to do that?
We seem a little upset.
We seem a little like, what's the word?
A little anxious, maybe.
She's so cute.
Ah!
Suit integrity compromised.
Maintenance required.
For your safety, access is restricted.
Oh.
Please utilize it.
Oh, sorry.
I interrupted.
The Minto Hugh?
Yeah, he's a little upset he's spaghetti.
He's a little...
You know.
His entire crew seems to have been killed somehow or
another.
He's allowed ample degrees of anxiety.
cortisol level spiked.
No, Hugh.
Your looks maxing.
No.
Rapidly repairs suit integrity and restores the wearer's HP.
Hold way to recover.
Very nice.
Okay.
Wait, there's probably gonna be like 15 of these guys behind
here.
Oh, nope.
Just a hole to space.
Maybe.
Why are there?
Have a nice dream.
Thank you!
I see the tram.
That could be our way out.
Oh my gosh.
Ball of safety.
Moon quakes.
I didn't know the moon could have quakes.
I've said this before in games, but I love when you can
tell, like, the scale.
the scope of a place you know like wow so is like she's just
really gripping
wait am i supposed to go oh here the towards the ball not
towards i hope any uh androids around that would be pretty
bad Wait, oh, shoot.
I did it, actually.
Where I, like...
I did it the thing where I did the D-pad instead of the
buttons.
Passing through more blue open nodes enhances hacking,
increasing damage, and keeping enemies exposed for longer.
Ah, neat.
I bet you used the D-pad.
I did.
I'll get used to it, yeah.
Are you hacking again?
That's right.
You're not going to get us in trouble, are you?
She's not.
She's so cute.
Yeah, why would it?
This is...
Okay, you don't get hurt by the explosions.
Good to know.
Uh...
There we go.
What does it be?
Oh, there we go.
Oh!
Not sure I can really count on you.
That's so true.
Dodging?
Oh!
Hurry!
Whoa!
dodging and jumping consume thruster gauge when the gauge
falls below a set level these actions are disabled whoo whoo
wait is this guy gonna come charging at me moon station goes
vintage no hack everything always good to have a dump a dump
a jump a jump dodge
What's wrong with me?
Why did I say that?
Okay.
Oh.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm nice and fast with it though.
I'm used to this.
I'm a hacker.
There's another one.
Let me handle it.
Where?
Oh, there it is.
I'm used to this.
I kind of want to practice dodging, though.
Oh, wait.
But this only stays a little packed for, like, a certain
amount of time, though.
And it says your...
Okay.
You better stay up there and get us to that tram.
It says your ammo, like, refreshes, like, recharges.
So I guess that means we...
Don't have to collect ammo.
That's always good for me.
The dodging will come.
Oh.
I'm assuming also we'll probably get upgrades.
Maybe, hopefully, for, like, our thing.
That would be pretty nice.
I'm going to jump over this.
What if it activates something?
What if they're just, like, unauthorized person passing
through the thing?
She's so sticky and cute.
no good can't do it what's that she's so smart what will we
do without you re-routing destination to the shelter
structural integrity of boarding docks below acceptable
parameters ceiling access level ceiling ceiling how am i
supposed to get back to my ship
Oh, oh.
Oh my gosh, we're going on a roller coaster.
Generic electricity sound.
What
the hell happened here?
Whoa.
Oh, it didn't entirely collapse.
Okay, though, I've once mentioned like a video game theme
park, we can add this to the rides.
So in Capcom theme park, you can ride the ball.
Okay, your turn.
Just, what are you?
I am DI03367, a state of the art pragmatic created here at
the cradle.
I possess basic life-saving protocols.
Okay, okay, that's enough.
I don't need the user's manual.
her do her spiel because she's so cute what the hell is
going on here don't cuss at her things trying to kill us i
don't know okay i can't believe they're all gone no your
friends there's something on my own now no we're together
hey uh d i i am d i zero three three six don't say it don't
say it don't say it don't you have a name or something i
said i am d i zero look how about we call you diana diana
yeah from now on you can be diana how's that been diana i'm
hugh i don't think she's so cute she's so confused and uh
Diana Yeah Diana Hue Diana Hue Diana Hue Diana
Hue Diana Hue Diana Hue Diana Diana Diana Hue Diana Hue
Diana She's so cute!
She's so cute!
Thank you.
One pragmatist, 100 men detected.
Welcome to the emergency shelter.
My heart can't take it.
She's so stinking cute.
Where are we?
I said welcome and I didn't pay attention.
Wait, can I climb?
I like how these things are called.
all day.
I can't run, though.
It's not letting me.
We mustn't scare the baby.
Oh.
Wow.
That is convenient.
Eat it.
Reactivating primary functions.
Whoa.
But that's the robots going rogue doesn't explain what
happened to the people, you know, in the cradle.
Let's Level zero.
Look at the forest!
All right.
The shelter.
Why is that super chat so cursed?
Let's see about getting patched through to earth.
Why isn't this working?
Uh oh.
Literally me when I'm hacking.
Oh my.
Zero.
are locked down but the comms tower
ah look at this the tram lane leading to the solar power
line is still running oh we got the main power back up we
can ride the rail all the way to the tower all the way home
it's not even that far
i want her big jacket What?
See this spot?
You think we can get here in one piece?
I...
I guess you wouldn't know that, would you?
Nope, but I have an idea.
Yeah?
Really?
Yeah, we'll go, and if you don't get hurt, that means it's
safe.
Let's go!
She's so right!
Sounds like a plan.
She's there.
Mint is our Diana?
What do you mean?
a serious actual like great logic she has the shelter is a
place away from prying eyes and enemy interference where you
can safely upgrade unlock abilities and adjust your loadout
you can also use the tram to travel around the cradle whoa
this is our little place wait this is our little place
i imagine we'll be able to unlock things and put stuff in
here?
Is that the tram?
What's over here?
Lockout controls.
We can decorate with pictures?
Maybe?
Yeah.
You have something you want to say?
She's looking at me.
Look at me i wish is there a first person oh sorry sorry my
bad my bad oh there's a zoom this this
made me jump what's this do a unit printer terminal for
acquiring or upgrading various items exchange luna filament
to upgrade weapons and hacking nodes or unlock new abilities
the odd different kinds.
Unit schematic not yet registered.
Solar?
Oh, then we gotta go to... Oh, it even tells you where to go
to get the weapon.
That's great.
Okay, everything's in the solar power plant.
Repair up.
We can get this, but we don't have enough filament.
Our very own 3D printer.
I'm gonna become a 3D printer person.
Be like, hey, you know that?
You want that thing?
I could 3D print it.
Oh, I really need this new thing.
Or I need this thing to fix my problem.
I could 3D print it.
Don't wet train her?
What's that mean?
An enhancement to Hughes thrusters.
Oh, yeah, I knew it.
I knew it.
Upgrade to your repair cartridge.
Oh, and then this is thing right here.
Firmware update.
Use upgrade components to enhance Hugh's primary unit or
suit performance and Diana's hacking ability.
Oh!
I have nothing.
I have no gold cubes.
Wow!
Look at her.
She's looking at it.
She's so curious.
That's Diana!
she's so happy to be upgraded oh hacking damage open
duration you guys can't see this but right now the open
duration is 1 and if you upgrade her it turns to 1.02
crazy if the north if the If, wait, bleh bleh bleh bleh bleh
bleh bleh bleh bleh bleh.
Dad for a son simulator, Pragmata's dad for daughter
simulator.
Yes.
The damage up.
Staggerate ammo capacity.
They'll stay the same.
Recoils, they're the same.
And the same is here.
Defense is currently one and we can go to 1.01.
Holy cow.
She's stepping around.
We could talk to her!
Well, let's try our best, Hugh.
Yeah, I'm gonna need your support till I'm back home.
Diana's absolutely so adorable.
I know!
It's pretty fun talking like this.
Let's talk a bunch while we have the chance.
Okay!
Oh, she's so happy.
Hacking seems pretty intense.
What exactly are you doing?
Um, well, I'm a state-of-the-art pragmatist that Ediths
can't control.
Yeah, so I've heard.
And like, I've always had this function that lets me
manipulate data transmissions.
Then one day I just tried it out.
Pretty cool, huh?
She just did it.
Oh, that is pretty wild.
So you're like some super adaptable AI bot?
I'm not some AI bot.
I'm a state of the art practitioner.
How dare you lower her title?
I feel like she wants to sell me cookies and yes, take my
buddy!
let me ask you something just how smart are you smart what's
that supposed to mean i don't have any special diana is
still taller than you so no she's there's no way look how
tiny she is yep no idea she's our actual child oh talk to
diana in the shelter read our memory replicator is standing
by whoa is everything in here talk not a moment of peace.
Diana is 4 foot 8.
That means she is... Wait, how tall is Hugh then?
Wait a second.
There's no way!
She's 4 foot 8?
Oh, sorry.
I keep running into her.
I want her to do her little...
I like her tippy-tappies as she walks around.
We're chasing.
We're having fun.
We're playing tag.
She's... But also, I am not 4 foot 8.
I am like...
like, I am taller than that.
I am taller than her.
How tall is Hugh then?
He's like, he's above seven feet with the suit.
Holy mo.
I mean, the shoes do add some lift, probably.
Can I jump over her?
Wait.
Wait, even, what if it's like a small jump?
That was a bit of a hold.
I could jump over I could jump over the child.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go to the solar place.
Okay, then.
Guess we should make for the power plant.
The power plant.
You can board the tram in the shelter.
Travel to tram stations in other sectors.
Sorry.
I think my coffee is wearing off.
Either the starting point or any open is skinny.
patch before departure review your loadout and make any
adjustments needed well i have i have nothing
you coming ride the trail to the soul i don't generator
entrance there we go sorry i mean do i lie that no idea what
what his height is oh i feel like seven foot makes sense
It's a little spooky in here.
Why is it so dark?
Guess no one's home.
I think this whole sector is in emergency mode.
What's in here?
Nothing.
It's pretty dark.
Not even the vending machine is working.
Warning, severe tremor detected.
Anomaly detected.
This power plant has entered emergency mode.
Cradle power output is currently limited to 35% of standard
capacity.
Trams and supplementary facilities are now non-operational.
To restore full functionality, restart the main power
generator on the top floor under administrator supervision.
I don't have that.
Oh, yes I got the golden cube!
No DLC outfits.
Mint doesn't get to see the cat ear suit.
Aw, Mint.
Yeah, my height is 5 foot 67... 6, 7...
inches.
So true.
Barble.
Looks like we have a power switch nearby.
Let's go find it.
We do.
Oh my gosh.
That way?
Oh yeah, it literally...
There's a literal arrow.
Are there guys...
Wait, this is the 3D printer thing, is it not?
Wait, so there's probably guys hiding in here, no?
I don't like that.
Ah!
Diana's scan ability analyzes the surrounding and marks
objectives or other important locations with icons.
Whoa!
Scan.
An ant!
That's the tram.
Oh.
It's in here.
Oh, wow.
And there.
What was this?
Lockdown procedures.
We got lore?
Tooleum from Alan.
Every rookie on the team gets thrown off by their first
lockdown drill.
You're not alone.
Just operate the terminal's location in the inactive sectors
to disengage the locks.
Most problems sort themselves out once you're at the
controls.
Good luck.
Tooleum from Jacob.
Why is he typed like that?
What?
I can't read.
It has come to my attention that a simple mistake I made got
caught on hologram, and now the recording is being spread
around the cradle.
I enjoy my work, but it doesn't foster a positive work
environment, knowing that everything I do could be the
subject of criticism or a joke.
to be recorded with such strict surveillance?
It's a block quote.
Huh?
The pointy is the original message.
Oh, wait.
It's not a bracket.
What's that?
The greater, less, wait, lesser.
I regret to inform you.
Upon joining the cradle, you agreed to a contract
acknowledging that all areas except for zones are subject to
continuous 24-hour surveillance.
Honestly, I sometimes wonder if the company is pushing the
boundaries with this policy.
Most likely the spacemen of the future will be way taller
than you since they won't grow up in a gravity well.
No!
Wait, do you think if you grew up without gravity, you would
just, you would just become a really long man?
Like all of your limbs would just extend forever because you
have no gravity holding you down?
Yes?
Your bones would be twigs.
Right.
Also very weak.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Spaghettiification.
Yeah, but your bones, yeah.
You would press a button and you would break your finger.
but i suppose delphi wants to leverage wait wants to
leverage its access to state-of-the-art tech to strengthen
security measures cradle-wide i'm sorry i could not provide
a more concrete answer but rest assured your concerns have
been noted
wait that's so wait i just i just re like realize what jacob
is saying so Jacob made a mistake and now everybody's
laughing at him because his mistake was caught on camera and
like every can you imagine people spreading around the
hologram being like where Jacob so Jacob's so stupid like
the Christmas party must be so bad because it's like oh
remember that every maybe everyone be like remember that
time Jacob was so stupid and then they pull up the hologram
they don't even pull up the video they pull up the hologram
so it's in like 3D of like you being a dummy dumb.
That's so mean!
Data saved.
So our battery is in there.
I'm looking around.
I'm scoping out the area.
We won't be... Okay, we might be ambushed by this guy.
Hacking objects.
I gotta get closer though.
Oh, wow, wow, this is such a great shot!
Wow!
Oh my gosh.
Space noir.
That's exactly what I was thinking.
Got it!
Back up generators.
Yippee!
The vending machines will work again.
That guy at the end is gonna wake up though, isn't it?
The top floor, huh?
How many floors are there anyway?
Yeah, that's a great question.
Hello?
I knew it!
That's what I said!
Wait!
Oh, oops.
We did it!
Yeah, yeah!
Style on his body.
something bad they knew it they knew it wait where was it
another one is this like a clean bar it's so funny wait jump
to dodge enemy attacks press our rival in mid-air oh oh
that's why okay oh ouch don't worry about it
you're detected nearby be careful yeah oh he's fast
so far so far okay I like the music a lot okay let's go back
to over here wait what is this thing a lamp
I know the robot doing the super model walk why is he so
like that oh Ah, wait!
What did I do wrong?
One, two, three, four.
Oh, I see!
Ouch!
Oh, oh, that's...
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wait.
Ah!
Oh, we got it.
Okay.
So slay.
Chancellor, thank you so much for that 20 gift.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
um you're not gonna wake up are you wait what's this okay
let's collect the loot first actually the game didn't
explain how it saves hmm look at our reflection okay from
handling small stuff they're not gonna have big tasks they
got it covered there are no kids here but if there were they
could probably handle them too what a strange thing to say
manual saves in the shelter common auto saves thank you
thank you we do it's just so much easier to let the walkers
handle it well i mean there's still plenty of work that only
a human can do like thinking up new innovations or new
business ventures to explore but anyway and Megan is strange
okay what a weird thing to say Megan hmm oh let me go in
there okay
I'm watching.
I'm watching you right there.
I'm guessing we can go into here.
Whoa, I just noticed this down here.
Wow!
Okay, but I'm like such a sucker for seeing the insides of
electronics and stuff.
Getting played inside his eyes.
Yeah, right, right.
Wait, where?
I hear him.
Oh, there you are.
Yay!
Good job!
Oh gosh, trying to get a headshot.
Nice.
Where'd that guy come from?
Oh, over here.
Wait a second.
Oh, you... Oh, shoot.
Ah, fuck.
I don't think aim assist is on.
I'm not sure.
Maybe I accidentally turned it off.
I'm not quite sure.
It is good to get these guys out of the way, though, for
whenever we come back to the tram.
Subtle.
Maybe it is subtle.
They don't hold your hand, huh?
What is this?
Look at the little car.
Too cute.
Alright.
Can't go in there.
Cute.
Cube.
Cube!
I see it.
The heck is this?
Maybe it's a lunif element printing error.
Whatever it is, it's in our way.
No, it looks like the stuff from outside, no?
Minto would have been a fan of the clearcase game boy they
all used.
Yeah!
No, this looks like the stuff that was, that, that took over
outside, no?
Oh.
Is that a cube?
No, that's just a thing.
What now?
Oh, oh.
Ah!
Wait.
Oh!
Eh.
Wait.
Uh.
Uh, dodge was...
That.
Do I need to...
Oh, I can shoot it.
I don't know why I thought that I needed to let her do it.
Oh, cool.
Wait, is there more?
Someone else?
Maybe not.
Maybe yes.
Maybe no?
Maybe not.
Okay, that's a thing.
Let's grab our cube.
Yeah, I did notice that hacking does damage because you can
upgrade it as well.
there was i think just for dodge though you just have
jumping and then you have this right yeah
which will i feel like we will want to upgrade that as soon
as we can so emergency lockdowns for all on-site locations
has been Please complete a manual reboot of the power plant
controller to fully restore operations.
Double locks, huh?
Double locks.
Starting to feel a bit unwelcome here.
I wonder if cradle staff have easy access.
Maybe?
I'm not sure.
We can't go this way.
We have to jump down.
Okay.
Gave is so pretty.
Oh, shoot.
Show him a bell.
Keep that company.
What?
Oh shoot!
Oh no!
Ow!
Be careful!
Oh my gosh, real combat now.
Oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Maybe I wasn't ready for this.
Ah!
I'm sorry!
Trapped in here?
Hacking?
Wait.
Oh my god.
18 HP in a dream.
We got this.
Oh wow.
Holy cow.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
The ambush took me out all of a sudden.
But we're fine.
Everything's good!
Can heal once with the bee.
Oh, emergency exit allows travel to and from the shelter.
Leads to the lower tram stop.
Hold LB on target to unlock and enable use.
Once at the shelter, you can upgrade.
I think they're telling us to upgrade before we continue.
Be aware that enemies will respawn when returning to explore
the cradle.
No!
That's so me!
reprint a new robot no no ah okay but at the same time use
this to go back to the shelter wouldn't it be to know maybe
I can get crazy I can head back for a Yeah, maybe I should
just repair or like should just heal though and we go back.
Hmm.
Upgrades though.
I know, right?
But we can heal by going back.
Yeah.
We'll go back.
I think it'd probably be easier.
Also, we can upgrade.
I think the upgrades are the bigger thing.
Oh, I think the upgrades are the bigger thing.
Thanks, Dider.
I mean, Denzatsu,
account oh yeah baby yeah let's power up our stuff can you
jump Diana jump I am glad we found that escape hatch she's
so cute me too nice having the tram come straight here means
we can swing by whenever mm-hmm especially if you forget
something uh-huh hey it could happen to you too you know it
won't because I don't have to carry anything fair enough so
edus is the main ai that oversees the cradle edus no edus
only manages the bots but those bots are pretty much
everywhere so edus is everywhere who the hell thought that
was a good idea every return to bases are through you know
the more i'm around you the more you seem like a real kid i
wonder how many bots like you are hanging around here not
because I'm specially made.
I'm D-I-03367.
A state-of-the-art pragmatic created here at the cradle.
Here you go again.
Let her do her spiel.
I heard you.
All right.
She's so cute.
But...
Oh.
Is there anything else?
Hugh, why did you come to the moon?
Work.
I got bills to pay.
This ain't a field trip.
We lost contact with the folks here, so we came to check
things out.
I thought it was just going to be signal interference or
something.
something it'll be okay Hugh space storms mess with signals
all the time so your guess was pretty good if you're trying
to make me feel better I appreciate it ah Diana if you ever
need anything let me know need all I really need to function
is a power source aside from that wait one way Diana how
you're holding up well Well, a quick scan shows all my
systems are operating normally.
So I guess you're doing okay.
So she's specially made.
I wonder if there's someone on the ship that, like, made
them after, like, their daughter or something.
Maybe, like, they had a daughter that passed away or
something.
They made her in her image, you know.
So, you ready to go?
Ready when you are.
Cute.
All right.
I want to upgrade
maybe maybe our Diana and also our gun I think it only does
the damage but damage is good too right more damage is
always good that's how I feel too right so I think we'll do
those two her hair is crazy it's so cute it's so unruly like
like for real like a real little kids more damage more
better yeah let's do it's also so funny because it also
feels like like a single dad you know doesn't know how to
brush his kids hair
Let's do Diana.
Let's upgrade our hacking.
Oh, it upgrades the hacking damage too.
Yeah!
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, and if we want to upgrade her again, it's only one cube
rather than two for like a...
Oh, so this one will do the stagger rate.
Sorry, I'm a little bit in the way of the things.
Do we have enough to do any upgrades here now?
Oh, uh, oh, we could do the repair up.
Repair output 350.
Well, let's wait a little bit to see what we get at the
solar power plant because we might get some good weapons
that we might really want or the hacking ability.
So we'll wait on that.
We'll wait on that.
And then I'm guessing this is the...
Mini cabin figures.
Nope, what is this?
Hi there.
Where are your fun little buddies?
Mini cabins.
If you spot us somewhere, give us a jolt.
And we'll beam right over to your living orders.
We get to decorate our house.
Functionality, zero.
Obsession with hanging out, maximum.
Collect more of us and prepare for eternal companionship.
That's all I could do.
ever what eternal companionship oh it's beautiful i love
that's how i feel whenever i get a figure i love plastic
okie dokie wait did i oh oh the things are online now oh i'm
floating through the skies a very pixely sky Wow.
What's this?
Rem Re- Re- Re-
Replicator.
What?
Okay, I guess we go back then.
You ready?
Diana, how are you holding on?
I can't stop talking to her.
A quick scan shows all my systems are operating normally
okay so i guess you're doing okay all right beautiful it's
so beautiful wow all right so we have to go back
ride the tram so yeah we do have to go back and do
everything again huh This place is huge.
Shelter one, two, three, four, five, six, eight, nine.
Nine flares.
Wait, I don't.
I have the checkpoint.
Will it take me back to the checkpoint?
It'll go back to the ladder.
Oh, that's what he meant.
Where is the ladder?
Ah!
Huh?
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I'm in here.
I didn't even realize.
I could go in here.
Oh, through the tram.
Just kidding.
Thanks, guys.
I'm just stomping all around through here.
Isn't it so convenient that we have a whole little system on
our back for Diana to hold on to?
Just testing us.
Oh, this is the plate.
Wait, hmm?
Is this it?
I like...
We're only 9% through.
That's crazy.
Extremely.
Oh, I see.
I was just being a silly.
Uh-oh, we forgot something.
Is that...
Oh, the collectible?
Uh-oh.
No.
Wait.
Is that a collectible?
It's fine.
Maybe.
There was a cargo rack.
No!
Oh my god, 100%?
But I want to decorate.
Decorations.
Restore power to the lunar base.
Yes.
sir oh oh cube
oh another cube okay we could do this we could do this
i don't know where it starts actually okay we're fine first
try the emergency lockdown for this area has been disabled
Yes.
There we go.
First one down.
But there's up there.
The cube.
Oh, there's another one right there.
By the cube.
Oh.
Down here.
Alright, so...
I'm just looking around.
What is that?
Wait, is that the gun?
New.
Shockwave gun.
Oh, my bad.
I was reading.
An attack unit.
Wait, we get a good set- a good- We get to hear the
soundtrack real good here.
Specializing in frontal suppression that fires powerful-
Close range!
Shock waves and makes enemies easier to stagger.
It becomes less effective as distance increases.
So yeah, a shotgun.
But it's a shock gun.
It's a shock, shock gun.
Wow, we can blow up the smithereens!
Unit schematic registry update.
Wait, but I don't think I printed it, or I don't think I
have it.
Yes, I do have it.
Oh.
Oh my god, wait, ah!
Initiated.
I was stupid.
I'm trapped.
There we go.
Oh.
Ah!
What are you?
Oh, wait.
Oh, shoot.
What is that?
Ah!
Oh, my god.
Wait, let me restart.
Oh!
Ah!
Shoot.
Uh, shoot.
Wait.
Oh, my god.
wait how did it say to restart it again can't remember this
guy is so slow look at him go
wait here we go hold on
wait oh my gosh i have to okay i really have to brain now
okay hold on one second
yeah he's a shooting to me can i just change my weapon there
we go this freaking thing is coming
Ha!
Yup!
We're getting it!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're getting it, we're getting it, we're getting it, we're
getting it.
Nice moves, thank you.
Uh, let's, uh...
Plik!
Oh, oops.
Oh, sorry.
Plik!
Got the second one?
Second.
All right.
Three left.
This away.
Anything else?
Sometimes it's hard to tell, I feel like with what's a thing
I can collect?
Oh.
Scan for things, you're so right.
Untime Lerker, first time Super Chat, my birthday tomorrow!
True Lieserker, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Thank you so much for the Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Really appreciate it.
Oh, like these, these, these are things, right?
Yeah, but it didn't show up in the...
We'll come back for that.
Yum.
Oh.
Something's aiming at.
Ow!
No, please.
Oh.
Ouch, ouch.
We got...
Oh, what's this?
Thank you.
That one's not good.
That one's not good at long distances.
She sure told me, didn't she?
Eh.
Nice.
Let's collect my earnings.
Let's collect the stuff over there as...
Oh, just kidding.
They want me to jump.
Here.
Oh, there's two ways.
Okay, okay.
Oh, there's the other gun.
I'll go to this one first.
I'll go to this one.
The robots are a little freaky, though, aren't they?
Sounds like an...
game chat response two more to go hey hey streamer don't
forget that that gun is not good for uh for long distances
okay just remember oh wait i can get two of them wait i'm
trying to figure out where does that jump down to if i go
there you know streamer why did you use that gun so close
Where does that go?
I want to get them.
Oh, I just...
Oh, okay.
Wait, I think I see.
Okay, we just have to go through the jumpy part again.
That's no biggie.
Yeah, only one way to find out.
So true.
Yes.
Upgrades, upgrades, upgrades.
Wow, there's so many around here.
Let's go.
What is that?
Oh.
it gets us back inside.
Anything down here though?
Oh, another gun?
And ah.
Wait a second.
The gun!
Wait!
Taking bets on when Diana mentions diagonal.
No!
Wait, the gun!
But we did get it.
The chest, yeah.
what are you
that's a lot of limb that's a oh it's still there that is a
lot of limb oh okay I'm learning now so you pick up guns
okay you pick up the gun only our grip gun which I'm
blocking actually Let me scoot over just a tad.
I'll even shrink some more.
The grip gun is good for...
Or rather, it has, like, unlimited ammo, basically.
It just recharges.
And...
Um, everything else we pick up...
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I am understanding.
Where...
How do I get back up?
Uppies?
Oh, this one!
Wait, did I need...
Grab it!
Lift your arms, Hugh!
Uppies?
This pushes out from the wall, so it's not like, uh, it's
not like, uh, I stand there and it raises, right?
Yeah, it comes out from the wall.
What?
Am I stupid?
Can I hack from...
Got it.
I needed to be super duper close to hack, but clearly that
is not the case at all.
Do I need to jump on to this?
I think so.
Yeah, nice.
We're gaming.
We are gamers.
I could go back and upgrade some more.
Honestly, let's grab some more stuff and then we can go back
and upgrade some more.
I'm ready.
Come on.
Yeah.
Come at me.
Go.
I'm a stupid inventory recently.
How are you?
I'm great, Quinn.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
All right.
Wait.
Okay.
We got two more to get.
Good job, gamers.
This is...
This is where the android came out, but it's not anything
now, is it?
I'm learning.
Hacking can be from further away.
All right.
Probably will be ambushed here as well.
What's going on?
Caution.
What's going on in there?
Was that one of them?
No, it wasn't.
What did that do?
Oh, I think I turned it off!
I turned off the lasers!
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Stasis net.
A tactical unit that fires a spherical electromagnetic net.
It expands on impact, immobilizing enemies within its radius
for a short time.
Duration varies by target.
Whoa.
Oh, neat!
Wow, you can get like two guys in there!
Oh, wow!
Okay, okay.
Oh.
Say sis.
You stop them and I'll pack them.
Yes, ma'am.
Emergency lockdown for this area has been disabled.
Nice.
That's a...
How many now?
She can count.
She's so good.
Wait, can I... Should I go in here?
Oh, there's one more in there.
Oh.
But I want to get to that.
There's also something over there.
Wait, there's so many things to hack.
Look at that one.
Oh!
Oh, gosh, that scared me.
Yay!
We take them out early?
Yeah, baby.
Nice.
That's one little...
Hacking online.
We are?
What are we hacking?
Oh, that guy.
Oh, the aim assist is aiming.
Isn't that great?
We're taking out the little...
Sometimes...
Ah, no!
We lost them.
Dang.
Oh, I see it now.
Yeah, sometimes it...
Okay.
It's fine.
I'm going to go back down here.
Something's aiming at us.
No, he's not.
But we can go over there, actually.
Wait.
How do I get up here?
Is there a ladder?
There is, like, some sort of ladder there.
Or maybe from...
Okay, hold on.
Sorry, I'm being a loot goblin right now.
Okay.
Maybe from, like, here.
Wait, can I reach that?
That's kind of scary.
Yeah!
Oh, oh, I'm styled.
Sick moves, Hugh.
Nice grind.
If this were a skateboarding game, I would have gotten major
points.
Wait, that's...
Wait, I wonder if I can...
Okay, hold on.
Look out for a targeting sensor.
We're fine, we're fine.
Yeah, yeah.
Stupid head.
I feel like I should...
I feel like I should be able to target that, no?
Nice.
Thank you.
And then we can go and grab that one too.
And then we could go down there and...
Fight!
Wait!
Something's aiming at us!
Ah!
Oh!
Oh, I made it.
Holy cow, that was close.
Um, not you.
Whoa.
Actually, he can't get us from up here.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh.
You can't get me, stupid.
I did not optimize my hacking.
Yeah, how do you like this?
We're cheesing it.
Hey.
Oh, uh...
Wait.
Maybe more like this.
Oh, we covered the whole map.
Yeah.
I'm Hugh.
And I'm too good.
Very nice.
Hey.
Cheese tastes good.
Where are we?
It's like the slowest laser ever.
What if it turned the corner though?
Oh no.
That would have been so bad.
What'd this do?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
I'm not sure what I mean, what does it do?
And this does.
Wow, we can ride it.
Wow.
we're going all over the place um did i want to do that
maybe okay we have more platforms now i guess that would
have been good for like blocking attacks from the the guy
okay actually i was gonna say i think i know where that last
one is though isn't it in the okay we're just gonna have to
be really careful here guys super ah
where is he oh
yeah yeah Nice dodge, thank you.
That is a lot of limb.
What's this?
Does it turn it off?
Yeah.
Two years of bogos, thank you!
Has the Oda humanity joke been made?
Actually, no.
Oh, so.
So this was just loot.
I love that.
I love it.
Oh my god!
Wait, wrong guy.
Here's my turn.
I like the combat.
Wait, they dropped Gaten's knee.
I like the combat in this game though.
I don't feel overwhelmed right now.
I thought I heard a guy walking around.
I think the last one was up there, wasn't it?
Wait, what's that?
Oh, maybe that's it.
So we had to get back up there again.
Which means I have to go this way.
The optional cheese.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mito is epic win.
Wait, there's some more.
Some more limb.
Yummy.
Yeah, it's right there.
Maybe...
Do I go in through here?
Because...
Maybe that's how I get through.
to avoid the I imagine these either we can't pass through
them or like they hurt us maybe
don't forget to heal I have a question about the healing
because if I use it now do I how do I get more later do I
craft it or do I buy it or does it just spawn again later
it recharges at the shelter every time you go back it
refills oh okay then we shall use it thank you thank you
I'm gonna try
there was an attempt let me see what happens if you just try
to go through the caution thing too because I didn't
actually try
I'm just assuming that I can't go through It might be
totally fine
No, come here, come here, come here, come here, come here,
my baby
What is this?
What are you?
What do I do with this thing?
Ow!
Well done!
Okay!
Tuna!
All right, let's attempt.
Oh.
Oh shoot.
Thank you.
I'm glad she backseated me actually.
Oh I didn't actually hack you.
Still, it's actually still okay.
No!
You evil!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Holy...
Holy cow!
Oh my god.
You almost got me good.
Maybe I should try this net.
Yeah.
He's not doing like any damage to this guy.
He's so tanky.
Please.
Jump you!
Yeah.
What do you mean is that it?
Mr. You have 54 health left.
Is that it?
Okay.
Sure.
Please complete a manual reboot of the power plant
controller.
That guy was...
Thank you.
That's fine!
That was the last of them.
Looks like the printing messed up here.
Definitely can't go that way.
Aww.
Cool, I like the way it looks.
I think though we should probably head back before we
continue onwards.
I think probably going back would be good before we continue
onwards.
And then we can also upgrade.
Because I got more stuff.
Yuppers.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe my health is like a tad low.
Maybe.
They'll respawn.
It's okay.
We have the door open.
Want to check if we can upgrade anything?
We can!
Where's that thing I like shot to?
Where is it?
Where's that thing?
Is it in here?
Where is it?
That big round thought from the world was pretty tough.
It was!
Get caught under that thing with no suit on and it's game
over.
What?
What is it even for?
Check the desk?
Oh, okay.
I'll work in anywhere with those guys stomping around.
Hmm.
I think they're supposed to work outside.
Now with Edith's acting all weird, they probably got moved
inside.
Hmm.
What's up, Q?
Anything I can help you with?
Why she looks so concerned.
I ever need some help.
I'll be sure to let you know.
Cute.
So, you ready to go?
Ready when you are.
Okay.
Yippee!
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god!
Look at!
Oh!
Oh wow, look at them!
Oh, he's bugging!
He's bugging!
And that guy...
Oh no.
He's fine.
He's fine with the clamp, I guess.
They're just little guys.
They're so cute.
Oh, we have six.
I do think maybe getting an upgrade on our health would be
good.
I...
And my defense.
Oh, we could do it again.
Ooh, tempting.
But I also think...
I think we could also upgrade everything, to be honest.
Like...
You think?
Try getting hit less?
Okay.
Yeah.
Good, good plan.
I think we should just upgrade everything.
Nice stagger.
Oh, this will do the recoil.
And then I'm thinking either we could do more Diana
or more suit.
But then if I do the suit, probably the next one will be
two.
So I think the hacking is so good though.
Riot.
They grow up so quickly.
Hacking is your best friend.
I mean, that's like the game, though.
Hmm.
But more defense is always good as well.
Can't go wrong with either.
That's how I feel.
I'd prioritize the daughter.
So true!
Having it open longer is good too.
Hmm.
Let's do...
Hacking.
And then we can go for the suit.
Ah!
I don't know.
Yeah.
I've made up my mind.
Yeah!
Nice.
Yes.
Hmm.
And then these attack units are a high class class of high
power weapons Specialized for inflicting heavy damage or
staggering enemies Performance scales according to upgrade
level Whoa tactical units are a class of weapons that okay,
so like the Yeah, the net
Unit schematic registry upgrades Okay Still don't have the
thing for the hacking yet.
But we do have our shockwave gun.
Can be equipped at the tram terminal level 1.
Rate of fire up.
Ammo capacity up.
Damage up.
How do I upgrade them though?
Hmm.
Did I have one right now?
No, I don't.
Let's craft one.
Let's craft our shockwave gun.
you upgrade it right here
oh wait though I have a question probably I imagine I
upgrade this but once it's out of ammo I lose it no so then
I would have to make a whole new one and upgrade it again
right i imagine that's probably the the situation it keeps
the upgrades it upgrades all drops as well
oh yeah yeah baby yeah baby yeah baby uh wait what's where
is it
where did it drop in here Where are you?
Where did it give it to me?
In the hallway.
Towards the tram.
Well, I still have a stasis net, which is why I didn't...
Why I didn't get a new one.
Is it in here?
Oh!
Will it give me?
it to me once i do this weapon load out oh oh yeah i mean
it's only level one but we could save it i suppose there we
go yeah it's so beautiful in here i'm obsessed i'm obsessed
okay Let's keep going.
Wait, equip mods.
What is that?
Very cozy, yeah.
Perks.
Oh, wow.
Literally everything reset.
Wait, that's kind of crazy.
That's fine, though.
Unlocked.
Wait, are these guys all back down here again then too?
Oh, they are.
That's okay.
I think I got everything.
That I wanted at least.
Nice.
What?
What's this do?
Can I call it up?
No, we're just going to drop down.
That's what I was thinking.
We're going down to go up.
what is this in here whoa can I go around this no okay
it's good if you want to farm money oh the shelter is
basically a bonfire you can go to heal but enemies respawn
yeah yeah but we were going to an area where you know we
weren't gonna have enemies oh so it's okay but I didn't
realize the lasers would even reset.
That's fine, man.
Hugh, look.
What's this?
That's the earth.
The blue part there is all ocean.
Look outside and you can see it from here.
That's weird.
Only got half of it here.
Yeah, what the heck?
Ah, okay.
The printer's busted.
It was mid-printing of the globe.
What a pretty room.
But the data here looks all right.
The ocean.
Water everywhere.
Kind of hard to appreciate when it says that.
Listen, if we get back to the shelter, I'll look you up a
new one.
Really?
I want to see.
A cute small spinning globe.
Some days the world can feel so big.
Other days, it can feel so very small.
this can be given to diana in this show we need to go back
to the shelter right now
i hear him tuna tuna tuna ew oh bingo tuna oh hue versus box
who would win Oh no, somebody left their their dehydrated
snacks.
All their helmets and stuff are here.
Oh wow, what a beautiful sunny morning.
What is this here?
Earth Memory Guide.
Thank you for purchasing Read Earth Memory.
Product ID 583.
Simply insert this REM chip into a supported replicator to
effortlessly generate furniture displays and more oh whether
you're looking to refresh your interior recreate a memorable
scene or set up a temporary office let your creativity guide
you dream shape live oh this week's replicator wait even the
food is replicated made are we eating plastics serving up
fresh nutritious replicator meals daily.
Only at the third floor cafeteria.
Today's menu is roast beef, seaweed salad, fish and chips.
Steiner, you hear that?
Even you can feel comfortable on the moon.
And pudding.
Thanks for your valuable feedback.
We remain committed to improving our replicator meals to
meet your taste and nutritional expectations.
Holographic meatloaf.
Research and replication department.
Yeah, moonslop.
Please forgive me.
To Kayla from Alex.
Sorry, I didn't tell you sooner, but I've received orders to
return to Earth.
Knowing how much you've wanted to go home, it's made this so
much harder to say.
While I know it's nothing special, please accept this batch
of rems.
I tried to pick up ones that reminded me of how you
described your place over the years.
what you never ate plastic food as a kid
ps please reach out once you're back home i'd really love to
spend more time together
please take these rams
what if kayla never goes home
what if kayla never got to go home she's got oh she's got
the meatloaf and a lot of cigarettes I'm guessing that's a
meatloaf I'm cracklers okay I can't whatever this sound is
it sounds like it's snoring that sounds like it's snoring oh
oh it was actually printing those stuff from the REM when I
think all went all hell broke loose
I gotta hurry and contact Earth.
Yeah we do.
We even have plants and everything.
Whoa.
What's this?
Welcome to the solar power plant.
The key to living on the moon and advancing research and
development was ensuring access to a stable power plant.
supply.
It's fair to say that the advanced systems in place at our
solar power plant has been the backbone for supporting
Delphi's development and expansion at the cradle.
Delphi Corporation.
Oh the doors are so dramatic.
Where do we want to go first?
What's this?
Oh wait.
Oh my bad.
LD.
Oh, I have to hold it.
Harden suit!
I got a mod!
Increases max HP by 10.
Helping mods boosts the civic abilities or grants special
effects.
Change loadouts at the tram, terminal menu, and the shelter.
That'll make your suit work better!
Nice!
So what's this?
Wait, hold on.
I'm still exploring before we...
cartridge holder oh nice yes we can oh awesome obtaining a
cartridge holder increases your maximum repair cartridge
capacity by one awesome imagine if our competitors start to
break in got the hands of a little filament eaters would
never let that happen I mean have you seen the bots it's got
running around here intruders wouldn't stand a chance some
of them are like freaking war machines yeah they are
they actually are i just wonder what all these little
devices are for thank you
words said before disaster yeah these guys are like war
machines like if they turned on us like oh no the potty is a
clear door what who who built this place what
no do you think it's like one of those doors that fogs up
when when you say that you're in there
no yeah maybe it darkens when you're there.
Maybe.
There was like a place that I would go to.
And I would only go to because the bathroom was like that.
It would like...
It was clear and then when you went in there it completely
fogged up.
And I would always go there just because I thought it was so
cool.
It's like my maid cafe.
It's not.
Do they record the hologram too?
oh no what if you have a what if the what if the the space
slot roast beef gives you a tummy ache reminds me of your
blue archive kevin no what if it gives you a tummy ache and
then everybody laughs at you no this has to be one of the
safe areas it must it must well there was a second door down
here so let's figure out let's see what this
Oh, oh my goodness, I'm so silly.
I didn't even realize.
Whoever gets to me a membership, thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I did say you're being monitored 24-7.
Now, the reason we're back...
Hey, back, you?
Oh, what do you want?
Let's get lots of REMs and decorate the shelter.
Oh, we have the present to give her.
Oh, I bet.
I didn't mean to press it.
Let's get lots of REMs.
Pretty weird, don't you think?
I think so, yeah.
What do you mean?
Everything we need is already at the cradle.
So why do we need earth stuff?
Well, people just like having things that remind them of
home, I think.
Being up here ain't easy.
So people hold on to whatever makes them...
and green isn't even i wonder if rm's will make me feel
better too do you feel bad oh look how cute she is do you
feel bad diana what's up you anything i can help if i ever
okay let's give her the present the globe
oh we got a a cabin coin What the...
A mysterious electronic coin featuring a smiling robot in a
hat.
Better hold on to it just in case.
Gift of Reed Earth.
Memory to Diana in the shelter imprinted using the Aryan
replicator.
I guess I'm yawning!
Well, Aryans have no real practical value.
They might keep her entertained for a while.
I'm gonna give it a spin.
Give it a whirl even.
Give it a world!
Oh my gosh, it gave her a little desk and everything.
What are all these?
Yay, that was fun!
She's died.
The glow makes the earth seem small.
Like it's easy to just go anywhere.
But I know it's actually way bigger than the moon.
Isn't that weird?
I thought the exact same thing when I was your age.
That if I worked hard enough, I could go anywhere.
Uh-huh.
Truth is, if you're up for it, nothing's stopping you.
Will she go back?
No, wait!
No!
I love the globe!
I thought it would be...
I thought it would be us looking at her talking, like, with
the globe.
She'll go back to it, I believe.
Maybe I'll play over.
We're there next.
There she goes.
Go.
Go play.
Awesome.
Okay, we got it, guys.
We got it.
Reload.
Look at her go.
She's spinning.
Oh.
Where did the crayons come from and stuff?
Spin.
She's so cute.
Okay.
Um, we only got one thing, but actually, this is good.
Because I can upgrade my suit.
So, now we're mostly even.
And my suit only requires still one gold cube.
Awesome.
Yeah, the mod too.
Yes, I was thinking that as well.
La la la la la la la la la.
La la la.
Equip the mod for my suit.
Customize your loadout to match the situation in battle.
Whoa.
How many can I have at a time?
There's so many of them, too.
Wow.
Weapons good.
Main, control, lobby.
Read Earth memory.
We missed one.
One for now, but he can upgrade.
Oh, okay.
It did show, like, mods.
Hmm.
Okay.
Very nice.
Alright, let's go through here.
Maybe we'll find the read memory around here.
Okay.
Music's kind of spooky.
Or was this a door?
Ah!
I almost missed it!
Oh, here it is.
How's it going?
To Young Bay from Kevin.
Things at the solar plant are in a word quiet.
Grunts like us show up in the morning and check out what the
bots have planned for the day.
we spend the rest of the shift trying to look busy I mean
though hello so we have kids I mean Diana might be a special
case she's just so cute but also I can't be mad either gets
you thinking we're both engineers but you ended up on the
front lines of lunar development and me wish I could be out
there too oh poor cabin did all the work leaving him bored
to tears man cry me a river are you bored too Hugh nah I'm
good kind of hard to get bored keeping up with your chit
chat oh my gosh I mean I get it though if I have a job and I
don't do anything at the job.
I get bored.
And then the time goes by so slowly.
You know?
I'm with you here.
No!
Oh.
Warning.
There.
New.
Stand clear of... Oh, this is glass.
Lockout control.
I see something shining over there too.
Hacking nodes.
Oh, this is a mod, isn't it?
Yellow have specific effects that trigger when passed
through while completing a hack.
Passing through multiple nodes at the same time increases
effectiveness.
These nodes can only be used a limited number of times.
You heard her.
Keep a yappy chat.
Well, there was, when I, when I haunted an office once, uh,
uh, sometimes I would get my work, like, halfway done
through the day, and then the rest of the day, I would just
make photoshopped, like, images of my friends doing, like,
really stupid stuff, you know?
I didn't know, I was so bored, I didn't know what else to
do.
A hacking node that disrupts enemy internal systems
temporarily increasing damage dealt.
And then if we go, booboo, booboo, booboo, booboo, booboo.
Holy fast!
That guy was hacking.
Whoever did that.
Holy moly.
We can use this to hit harder and beat things faster.
Yeah.
Was it a mod though?
Shoot.
Look, you look!
Shoot now!
Oh, oops.
He left a heart!
Nope, that's a net.
Just kidding.
Sorry, from there it looks like a heart, doesn't it?
I shot to the left.
I shot to the right.
Tuna?
That's a lamp.
More decode!
This will make it easier to hit things harder.
There he is.
What is he saying anyway?
I don't even know.
Let's go up here first.
Loot.
This is why we explore everybody.
Yeah.
I think that's everything.
Gamers don't look up.
This looks...
Suspiciously arena.
Suspiciously arena-like, if I do say so myself.
No fall damage.
Poggers.
You're right.
Yeah, it's very arena-shaped.
This goes up, though.
Wow.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Five things in the middle, huh?
This is a more hidden wall.
Oh, wait.
There is a more hidden wall.
What do you mean?
What do you mean a more hidden wall?
Like here?
I can't jump.
Back up at the top.
Really?
Secret wall at the top?
Wait, I want to see it so that I can know for future.
This?
Where'd the wall go?
It was just a hologram.
these things around here.
Stay sharp.
Whoa!
The hollow...
I thought I heard a guy.
The hollow wall.
Looks like my theory was right all along.
And here you are to prove it.
Welcome.
Behold my latest creation.
The hollow wall.
At first glance, it almost looks real, but tactical
inspection quickly proves otherwise.
I even installed the very first model right here to
celebrate this monumental breakthrough.
Well theoretically, I always knew it was possible
holographic projection data combined with a Luna filament
solid solidification.
But proper testing required a real experimental setup.
Huge power supply and expensive materials.
I begged my boss for approval but the request never went
through.
Then again I doubt standard personnel ever had access to
limb structure data anyway.
But that's irrelevant now.
What truly matters is exploring the endless possibilities
that lie ahead.
Sharon.
Thanks, Sharon.
But also...
Crayons!
A vibrant set of crayons, often the first tool to one's
artistic journey.
Is that another REM?
Sure is.
Let's take it back to the shelf.
Where is this?
Oh, I know.
where this is!
Wait!
That's at the very beginning!
Oh my goodness.
Yeah, now she can draw stuff for us.
Where?
Is there anything in here?
No.
Very cool.
Thank you so much, guys.
This way.
Oh, just kidding.
I thought it was another block.
Okay.
Let's prepare our ourselves for whatever will happen here.
Got it!
Uh-oh.
Yeah!
I knew it.
Intrigues detected.
We shall move here in front of the menaceous.
Whoa!
Starting pack!
Alright, where is the thing that's aiming at us anyway?
Looking up for a targeting center.
Storm!
You're on?
Where?
Or this guy.
Is this the guy that we're worried about?
Holy cow.
Ah!
Jump!
I tried jumping.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, you can't aim a jump, obviously.
Nice.
I like that you don't have to get every single one.
It definitely helps to get more than one.
I'll hack the lift if you're ready.
Uh, yeah.
One second.
Can't go that way?
Blammo.
Yeah, get that guy.
Get him good.
Okay, we'll hack the lift.
Now that we're ready.
Sometimes just better to finish faster.
Yeah, that's what I think too.
Are we there yet?
But these are good.
These were nice to have.
The game is friendly.
Thank you, Gim.
Reach the top level.
of his facility.
We did it!
Now where do we find the main power terminal?
Aw, man.
I want the shockwave.
Wait, there's a lot of stuff around here.
Wait, this is also looking quite arena-shaped, is it not?
Totally not a boss room, right?
With ample supplies!
Oh, yeah.
This could never be a boss room.
Hmm.
time to heal yeah right like
we'll get more to those
I'm just looking around at the moment oh there's another box
over there
here oh two more boxes three more boxes Totally safe.
E this guarantee, is it?
Absolutely.
They're robots.
They work for us.
Holy cow.
Okay, there's a lot of stuff.
ABS always be scanning.
You're right.
Oh, I like the way it looks, though.
It's pretty, no?
I think
that's...
That's it though.
Alright.
Oh, you could shoot the boxes?
Oh, good to know.
Here we go!
One,
three, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one,
one, one, one, one, one, one, Lockdown disengaged.
Reconnecting primary power.
energy levels at 30% 40% 50% Wow 60% uh-oh warning you
unauthorized access detective severing primary connection
this is Edith unregistered guests are forbidden from this
area.
Initializing sector guard protocol.
Scanning.
Target identified.
Neutralizing threats.
Ah!
I thought we're gonna have to fight all the way through.
Get ready.
Uh-oh.
Whoa!
I never seen it before.
Alright buddies, then I guess we can just go in blasting.
Uh...
Uh, shoot.
Where do I shoot though?
Not quite sure.
Woo!
Uh...
Maybe there?
Wow!
Uh, wow!
Woo!
Move!
Oh, shoot.
Come on.
You're done already.
Oh, no.
I have to rehack, don't I?
Come here, Cabrera.
Oh, no, I don't.
Uh, yes, I do.
Wait.
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
Oh.
Two, watch out.
Woo!
Let's grab another.
Oh, my God.
He's right there, isn't he?
Ha ha ha.
Thing, I don't have to redo it, right?
Ow!
Oh!
Enough already!
Grab that.
Oh!
He's not that fast.
He's kind of fast.
Oh!
Wait, let's get closer.
Oh, oops.
If I could hit him, that'd be great.
Oh, I have more.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm running, I'm running.
Big damage.
Oh, unleash a critical shot, a powerful follow-up to it.
attack when near a downed enemy!
RT.
Now's your chance!
I'm...
Oh, nice!
Woo!
Nice!
See,
down again?
Oh, base two?
Uh-oh.
Base two?
Yeah!
You bastard!
What do you mean?
mean let you try?
Oh.
Overdrive protocol.
Whoa!
When the hacking gauge fills.
What do you mean the hacking gauge?
She's ulting.
Diana's ability Overdrive protocol can be activated.
When used, it opens nearby enemies and mobilizes them
briefly and deals damage.
The gauge fills by hacking.
Press L Stick, our stick when the hacking gauge is full to
activate.
Look at her goal!
Oh my god, she's the perfect super hacker.
Whoa, where did that come from?
Come on, I think it really did something.
Come on, come on.
Reload.
Oh my god, I like sandwiched that.
Okay, nice.
We need to hack you again.
Shoot now!
Oh!
Woo!
He came right at me!
Oh shoot.
I need another gun.
Where are you gonna come again?
Uh...
Run!
Mega damage!
Oh my god, this is so fun though.
Because there's so many different things you can do!
Oh, we are close.
Yeah, she's so right.
She's such a good like motivator.
Um, attack again.
Oh!
That's fine.
Nice.
Split it wide open.
Yippee!
Unanswered levels.
Restored.
Yeah!
Yeah, baby!
We did it!
No, don't...
This is how we say good job.
Oh my god, she just registered that to memory.
Good job.
Yeah.
Yeah, money!
Shelter license key.
A key card that raises your shelter access level.
new functions in the shelter yeah well let's just take it
back to the shelter i feel like we could repurpose this i
think we should take him back home oh i wanted to go get
that defense thing though
are we back home we are a new destination has been added to
the tram line the mass production array is now accessible
yeah i want to make our own mech
Imagine, I have a pilot seat and she sits right next to me.
Is this the new Mega Man?
That should take care of the cradle's power problem.
Next up, the MTA and the cost tower.
Woo!
We have blocks.
What is that?
I wonder if we're gonna meet any other people.
What is that thing?
I'm gonna get a better look.
Wait!
we have a little guy we have a wait does he have a hat wait
is he the guy careful hello we are cabin companion for all
things shelter so where you been all this time we believe
you have a shelter license key in your possession this thing
we wanted out the giant bot yeah Ah.
What up?
A most pointed inquiry.
We have been, let us say, asleep.
But that device woke us up.
Oh my god.
Leaving us available to offer you.
Why did he turn his face to smile at her?
The mission is confirmed.
For shelter, level one.
Yippee!
Search terminals now loaded with shiny new stuff.
REM Replicator Beta now online So many more So many more
gifts The shelter is equipped with a level system Deliver a
shelter I always thought that the level zero meant like That
It was like The level zero of the Like you know how there's
a first story A second story in there I thought we were at
the zero story Like of the building Yeah like the under
ground.
Yeah, yeah, I thought it was like ground floor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's...
The shelter is equipped with the level system.
Deliver a shelter key license to cabin to increase the
shelter's level and unlock additional functions.
He's so cute.
Why is every character in this so good?
Hello, fellow cradle crew.
Allow us to enhance your shelter life experience with our
newest service.
What's that?
cabin staff club exchange cabin coins to unlock shelter
surfaces a little quid pro coin please accept this gratuity
for first-time crew one cabin coin compliments of the
shelter hello thank you take a look at our fine selection of
stamp boards jukebox jukebox
everything is so like
This game's gonna make me cry, isn't it?
No!
I just know this game is gonna make me cry.
Comfy Moy.
Yeah, that's exactly what this is.
I already want the...
I already want the OST.
High possibility.
Obviously no spoilers, but man.
Ooh,
this one's very space.
This one's so creepy space.
I like this one, though.
Cabin Stamp Club.
Spend cabin coins to claim prizes from an open slot on the
stamp board.
Complete a bingo to receive additional awards.
Bingo, bingo, bingo.
two.
Is this a free bot data?
Walker bot data will be uploaded to the bot database in the
shelter.
Locked section.
We match!
I also
want the DLC I want the DLC Lunar Aqua No, that's a mint
outfit We need the Triple bingo Bingo So let's just do Oh
skirmisher.
10% more weapon or hacking damage against downed or
immobilized enemies.
I already wanted to be a dad.
I've known that but I hadn't even heard of this game until
saw the first introduction scene on Twitter and immediately
I'm buying this tonight.
Oh my god.
Oh yes, this is one of our more popular items.
I'm kind of confused by this.
by this let's try this one oh wait this would be a bingo no
to get blackout you have to fill the card okay okay read
more about bots here oh operational summaries of bots
deployed within the cradle detailed 3d scans of their
designs are also available an impeccable choice we have to
we have to do the entire thing, guys, so we can get the
blackout outfit.
I don't have any more coins, though.
Thank you!
Much appreciated.
Ugh.
Schematics.
The water!
Oh.
What's what?
Oh, she's looking.
She's curious.
Hey, look.
This terminal has bot data saved in it.
Yeah.
Wow, look at that, you can see everything!
I can see all his little insides!
Oh wow, he has the same thing that the big bot had.
That's cool.
Buy DLC before the 24th to get pre-order outfits.
Yeah!
If you guys want the pre-order outfits.
Oh, so cute.
battery maybe press Y oh my god cool Wow
yeah let's see we have a gift
there's more here we must this is that the symbol for beta
update upgrade limits expanded across the shelter we have
two again talk
to Diana I will I will hold your horses be patient be
patient you guys I'm just seeing all this stuff too.
Decode!
Oh, this is the...
One that... Yeah, yeah, the damage, but we have multi-hack.
Hacking node that links enemies together!
Wait, that's huge!
That's good.
I can't believe that terminal has my data in it.
Yeah, open time is extended.
That's so nice.
Oh my gosh.
Look, it got all three of them.
That's awesome.
Abilities.
I'm guessing these are the mods.
Right, maybe?
Unlocks Critical Shot.
When an enemy's health is low, a critical shot.
Sorry, critical shot never may appear.
Passing it through a hackle down enemies.
Neat.
Fast moves.
Press...
Oh, it's...
Like a perfect...
Like...
Yes, yes.
Interesting.
Permanent skills.
Oh, really?
We have none of these, though, so we can't purchase any of
them.
Attachments.
A new mod slot!
Node slot.
Overdrive.
Enhance his overdrive protocol.
And the hacking gauge is full.
Yeah, yeah.
Ooh.
Hacking gauge.
Upgrade to enhance Diana's hacking gauge.
Creates his hacking gauge buildup from completed hacks.
I think that's a good one, too.
Oh, wow.
We're getting all the good stuff now.
Let's go.
Wait, though.
Max targets up.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, it's a good one.
It's all good, right?
I think it may be.
Increases Overdrives Protocol Damage.
Open duration and stun time.
Nice.
What's nice is...
These are all like level 2, so we could just kind of like...
I do think a mod slot would be good, though, right, huh?
But I only have one mod, no?
More things to equip.
do the mods slot we still have enough for another thing
though
i could get three i could get three mods oh thrusters is
great i think so too honestly yeah i was thinking that
actually this is like one of the things that i wanted to
upgrade first huh when i was like oh yeah we'll upgrade the
thrusters later yeah yeah yeah good good good more dodge
always good i just beat the game i hope you had fun it's a
crazy ride i want to be it i want to play i want to play
oh yeah what all do we have now what the heck when did i get
this one with the hair when did i get the one with the hair
interesting wait since when did we have dice since we
printed the globe they both appeared at the same time they
did i see looks like we got some freebies cool freebies the
person who made that rem put in a little extra to cheer us
up i see i want to tell the person who made it that i liked
it a lot i'm sure they got the message i don't i don't think
you can all right come here i'm gonna give you a present the
crayons
yes yes draw for me draw I want to hang it on my
refrigerator hey can I give you something yeah thanks for
talking to me all the time is this supposed to be when we
first oh my god uh-huh I drew it it's for you and look at
that You wrote your name too.
Not half bad, kid.
Receive a picture as a present.
I've been wanting to draw forever.
I'll draw you too.
She already has.
Look, there I am!
She's using me as reference.
And she drew the bonds too!
What are you doing?
They're like spewing blue.
And she drew the spaceship?
Too stinking cute.
Oh Cabin do you see her?
Do you see her?
He's frozen.
Oh, he's listening to me.
He's like what are you gonna say, bud?
We have another stamp.
We'll get another secret ring.
Crusher bot data.
Ooh!
Bingo!
Thank you.
What did I get?
Cartridge holder.
Oh, nice!
That's big too!
That's awesome.
There better be a fridge you can put that picture on.
Yeah, where does the picture go?
Much appreciated.
Let's go see our guy.
Whoa!
Wait, what's it say?
Diana, this one's rude.
really good at stomping its feet, huh?
Floating around like that looks so fun.
Wish I could do that too.
Open.
She's talking back there about how much she loves.
Maybe I can get this one to you.
It's good.
Yeah.
They're all good, Diana.
Look on the side of the console.
she's drawing she's drawing i like how i looked up at it so
cute now
that the power's back on we can take the trance somewhere
new i know now we can head to the comms tower right yep it's
in the mass production array oh that sounds bad long enough
wait mass production of what finally call home wait mass
product what's a mess what are we mass producing What's up,
Q?
Anything I can help you with?
If I ever need some help, I'll be sure to let you know.
This guy's just entertaining himself.
What are you doing?
Hmm?
What's that?
What is that?
Hey, look.
This terminal has bot data saved in it.
She's so stinking cute.
What are you doing?
Oh?
What is he doing?
Mega man?
He doesn't want me to look at him.
He keeps turning around.
He's shy, I think.
Hi.
You'll hear a noise if his face changes.
Okay.
Okay, now we can actually buy something here.
Bito will catch baby fever from this.
Speak for yourself.
I think everybody else has baby fever too.
Wow, the hacking is kind of huge because it's so much... You
get the...
Here.
You get everything.
The primary unit's kind of tough because it's like...
One thing at a time, right?
The suit upgrade is also nice because you get both HP and
defense.
We're all infected here.
The hacking is pretty nice, too.
Mega Mad Noise is Awakening Memories.
Which will you choose?
I don't know.
Open duration is really good.
And the damage more is good too.
Wait, heat gauge buildup.
We should do that then because we should do that so we can
do the heat gauge buildup too.
Yeah!
More hacking!
I like that our hacking is at level 5.
Everything else is all even.
Yeah.
Well guys, I think I will call it here for today.
I even went overtime a little bit.
It's just, oh, wait, I really like this game.
I think this is a good place to call it though.
I've been playing with that.
You have?
Look at her little steps.
She likes the globe.
will come back though we will come back to diana and
pragmata and cabin wait can i jump on him
wait i want to jump on his head no please let me jump on his
head
sold i'm buying this yippee I'm really, really enjoying it
so far.
Look at...
She's looking up the little guys.
I think it's so charming, and it's actually, like,
legitimately fun.
I was going to pass on this one due to the lack of free
time, but you saw me, Bono.
See you using the link.
Thanks for introducing us to such a cool game.
Thank you, Dorgo!
Thank you.
I mean, I know that I've only played for a little bit.
I'm not super far in the game, but, like, I'm getting...
The vibes are so good.
It looks so good.
It plays so good.
Like...
And I'm not even...
I'm not even saying all this just because it's a sponsor.
Like, legitimately.
Potential...
Potential game of the year.
The vibes are so good, though.
It is a breath of fresh air, truly.
Played it for a few hours.
Tone was not what I was expecting.
Hmm.
yeah capcom cooking yippee but we will we will play more of
it so thank you again capcom for sponsoring um i mean i was
i was excited to check this out anyway because it diana is
just so stinking cute but we will we will we will come back
for more and go to where are we going to Anyway, I kind of
want to see.
Oh wait, it was the mass production area, was it not?
Weapon loadout.
Hacking nodes.
Yeah, multi-hack.
Yeah, mass production array.
That doesn't sound so good.
That sounds kind of scary.
Maybe.
That sounds kind of...
What are we mass-producing?
Look at that!
Oh my gosh!
Oh no, it says that I've only done 72% of the solar power
plant!
What did I miss?
Two safe...
Or a safe box.
I did miss.
And then the thing here.
Wait.
I missed one of the special things to unlock.
There are some areas you can only get to later.
Oh really?
Some of these things you can only get to later.
Okay, okay, okay.
Make sense, make sense.
I wonder if maybe there was like a hidden wall or something
as well.
It's anyways, solid launch with new IP and no major bugs
from Capcom.
Yay!
I know the fact that it's a new IP too is so great.
Oh, thank you for playing, Ninto.
Now time to fire it up and play through myself.
No spoilers.
I know I'm going to be slower than everyone else, so...
The sealed door.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
You're right.
But we will head to the mass production array next time.
Okay, good.
Time to add this to my schedule for this coming week.
Maybe we have Pragmatasundays.
Or something.
Yippee!
Thank you guys so much.
I really appreciate...
Once that's the comms tower.
Should be at the mass production level.
Appreciate you guys hanging out with me.
I'm trying to figure out.
There we go.
Save.
Yeah.
Thank you everyone.
Thank you again, Capcom.
And if you guys are interested, if you are also want...
If you're just curious about it, if you watch them, we're
curious.
There is the...
demo so um feel free to download that and give your own
thoughts as well so it was a lot of fun i had so much fun
too yeah pragmato yeah thank you guys thank you thank you
thank you and um i will see you guys when i see you next
thanks for the stream thank you thank you Watch everything,
everyone!
Have a good day, have a good night, and I will see you when
I see you next!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
Guys, I'm sorry.
I went to the main menu because I was like, I wonder if it's
one of those games where the main menu changes.
And it is!
Look at them!
Talking to each other!
Oh no, it's so cute!
I just wanted to show that Okay Okay bye